loneliness is your body's signal that
you need to connect just like thirst and
hunger are a signal that you need to eat
or drink and so if you're feeling it you
should take that as you should take that
seriously should take that as a warning
Lydia has there ever been a better time
to be talking about friendship it's
pretty top of mind these days isn't it
right now it's critical that we hang out
with our friends that we help fights I'm
sorry you know what I shouldn't be
saying that right now we shouldn't be
hanging out and so the thing is that our
need to connect is a fundamental piece
of the fabric of society and of what it
is to be human and so we have to find
ways to be with our friends from a
distance right now we have to show up
from a distance yeah I suppose that
previously if we'd had a global pandemic
at any other time in human history we
wouldn't have had the technology to
facilitate this our our tech friendship
that we're about to have for the next 45
minutes or so you know like no that's
right you know and the irony is that so
many people are so worried about the
effects of Technology and digit and the
sort of digital revolution on friendship
and on social interaction but right now
the the timing is perfect for us to
embrace digital friendship and all that
it has to offer
and I hope what we do is that from this
experience we take the good and then you
know we get back to spending some time
in real life with people I mean that
should never go away as being important
but since we can't do that right at this
moment there are we are really fortunate
that we have these ways to connect and
in fact I'm having more zoom video
conferencing with my friends that in
fact I never did that with my friends I
only did it for work and now everybody
wants to have a zoom conference it's
really kind of hilarious yeah that's
kind of funny this proxy for friendship
that we've got so I'm
how do you define a friendship well
what's really interesting is that when
biologists and neuroscientists and
anthropologists really set out to study
friendship more seriously recently one
of the things that they were trying to
do from the start was define it and and
measure it you know figure out what it
was exactly because in science you have
to be able to met you have to be able to
measure you need definitions and really
it comes down to a very simple sort of
minimal there are three minimal
requirements a friendship is a
relationship that's long lasting so it's
stable and reliable you know somebody
you've known a while it's positive it
makes you feel good both of you and it's
reciprocal so there's cooperation
involved so you have to have
give-and-take right it can't just be it
can't be lopsided let's say I wonder how
many people who have friendships or that
think that they have friendships when
applying them to those criteria would
realize that they absolutely definitely
don't have friendships well this is the
thing it's three legs of the stool right
and and a lot of us have to but we maybe
don't always have the third consistently
and now I should also say that in human
friendships you can have a lot of other
things too I mean there can be people
like two people think of loyalty and
Trust and things like that and that's
all great but without those three things
I mentioned you know you're not quite
there and so one of the things that
comes up the most often is that we have
a lot of longtime relationships but that
don't always make us feel good that can
be even it could be ambivalent or worse
but that and sometimes we hang on to
them just because you know there's a lot
of history there and so I think that one
of the things that the science of
friendship should do is get people
thinking a little harder about who's in
their life and why and what they get out
of it and and what it might cost them I
couldn't agree more I'm a big proponent
of people questioning who is in their
life you know the you right we kind of
grandfather these old artifacts of a
past life in
you know the the guy who used to be a
rugby American football bro back when he
was 18 but now after two doctorates and
a bunch of other stuff and he still got
these friends and there's a bit of a
juxtaposition and he doesn't really know
how how that works you know it's it is
interesting so why did friendships
evolve why do we have them well we have
them really fundamentally we have them
to help protect us against the stresses
of day-to-day life and but they evolved
initially as a way to protect against
predators I mean quite literally the
lion on the savanna in Africa and and
also as a way to help find food and
things like that and then they evolved
because in order to solve those kinds of
problems early humans had to live in
groups and even other animals had to
live in groups and like non-human
primates living groups and they do that
to protect themselves and to better
their chances of survival and the more
individuals are in your group the more
complex the social interaction is and so
that is part of the explanation for why
we have the brains that we have you know
the size of our brains is partly
dictated by the complexities of our
social world and so you know there
aren't lions in most of our lives today
anymore literally except there are
plenty of figurative lions you know I
live in New York City and there's
challenges to living in New York City
today and my friends are really there to
help me get through those but the
important thing is that our brains are
very we feel rewarded by the time we
spend with friends we really enjoy it
and that reward that says reward is part
of what makes us keep coming back and
sort of deepen the relationship so that
those people are there when we need them
or they need us I get it so is the
reason that we feel good around friends
that that would have been Fitness
enhancing evolutionarily yes yes
absolutely so often we feel we enjoy the
things that we should do more of now of
course there's a little complicated
because there are some things we do
that we enjoy that are not always so
great for us but it is very much true
that the reward centers in the brain are
generally designed to encourage behavior
that is going to help us survive it's
going to increase our fitness and so
enjoying the fun that we have with
friends is is not just a sort of
byproduct it's it is there for a reason
it's you know so the pleasure we get
from each other is is really it's not
just psychological but physiological I
mean the way for instance our bodies
produce neurotransmitters like oxytocin
that make us that increase our bonding
with a person and not just you know we
think of oxytocin as something between
mothers and babies perhaps and it is
it's it's released when mothers are
nursing newborns and things like that
but it also is released in in other
people who are just friends when they're
interacting and so it's strengthening
the tie it's making you feel stronger
about your relationship with somebody
and then that makes you keep keeps you
coming back how many friendships can I
have because I've got like two and a
half thousand friends on Facebook so
yeah many people not in the same way you
can you can be Facebook friends with
that many people and I up the reason and
you are and and I I am too I have
thousands of friends on Facebook but but
you so interestingly quality is more
important than quantity and when it
comes to your health the most the
biggest difference the step change is
between zero and one friends so really
truly if you have just one friend you
are better off by a mile then if you
have none but most of us in our in our
inner circle have an average of four
really good friends or people that we
really feel are essential to our life
and that is usually split between family
and friends but most of us don't have
more than say six like eight would be
really unusual and and so like I say
four is the average and so we're not
saying you have to be the life of the
party your Facebook friends are
something different I'm guessing that
some of those people are people that you
really see a lot outside of you know in
your on offline life and some of them
are people that you barely know or if
you have ever met them at all and that's
just it's a different that's a different
thing and we know the difference by the
way between Facebook friends and actual
friends that's why we use the phrase
Facebook friends not really friends with
them
you were talking there about the the
fact that we've got gradations of
friends you could call it friendship
what is it that makes someone be part of
the 1 or the 3 or the 6 and someone be
part of everything else what's the
difference really just how how close you
are how how much you like each other how
friendship is about it literally is
about a difference a differentiation in
the relationships meaning that you know
I'm closer to this person than to that
person and that's okay I mean one of its
sort of interesting because a lot of
times we feel badly about that but we
don't we just don't have enough time to
be friends in the same way with everyone
in the world and it doesn't necessarily
mean that we don't like the other people
it's just that we are for whatever
reason we got drawn to the people we're
close to usually it's things like
similarity and proximity you know that
play a part and there's a chemistry to
friendship just like there is to romance
you know you get there are people you
meet and you think wow I really think I
could be friends with her or him you
know right from the start and but it
still takes time you have to put in the
hours but so that same kind of liking
that that comes from I mean from
anything you find somebody funny you
have similar sense of humor or you have
a similar background and experience so
you have a lot in common to talk about
or you've been through something similar
like I I happen I'm noticing with
coronavirus that there are you know
there are people who are on the cruise
ships together who have become good
friends and they've been texting each
other when they're in quarantine so
they've been through the same hard
experience
and then that that helps you bond with
people so there's all different kinds of
ways to become friends I've got a
similar experience to that I was on a
show called love island in the UK a
traumatic experience where I was locking
with a bunch of other people and I
couldn't escape were honest you know
it's I completely understand where
they're coming from and you know
interestingly from that a lot of the
people that were on the show they're
still bonded you know a bunch of them
are out and to buy together at the
moment it's a very unique experience
that brings everyone together one thing
that I brought up the other day actually
on a podcast with Morgan Housel
I'd be interested to hear your thoughts
on this is at the moment with the corona
virus outbreak it is one of the very few
things which happens globally you know
it doesn't even rain everywhere in the
world at the same time it's you know
you're the markets don't even open the
chinese-japanese markets don't open the
same time as New York Stock Exchange the
same time as the German market and it is
bizarre at the moment seeing people
pulling together against this common foe
in a little bit of a way it's odd that
you have something that's so universally
felt yes I agree completely I was having
the same thought today as I was reading
about the restrictions and various
countries and how you know how similar
it's going to end up being you know
everybody some countries are catching up
to where others were but I think we
really are all we are literally in the
same boat we are literally on the same
planet suffering from the same problem
right now and and the you know the good
thing here is that in that I mean
friendship even though we need to keep
our distance from each other friendship
really is fundamentally that that
reciprocal cooperative part is about a
willingness to help in times of crisis
especially and so that is where we are
right and we just have to think a little
bit more creatively all of us about how
to help and you know how to do it like I
said from a distance but but yes we're
bonding over this shared bizarre
experience where
yeah it's a great equalizer you know I
think I don't know much about people
from China you know I don't know what
side of the road they're driving I don't
know if they said hello to me I'd
probably not know what word it was you
know I'm so I don't have they
essentially could be a different species
or from a different planet
but I know that their physiology is
reacting to the kovat 19 outbreak the
same way that mine is the same way that
my mum's is that parents are the same as
my parents are the same as my you know
yeah yeah I genuinely do wonder
obviously massive tragedy I do not want
this to happen given the choice between
the world without it in the world with
it I would much sooner that it wasn't
here but trying to you know draw some
silver linings from around this cloud is
I certainly feel more empathic towards
people globally and I'm my empathy
scribbling like I don't need any more of
it known on a daily basis but I have
even more now that makes sense it does I
mean I'm glad to hear you say that
unfortunately not everyone is the same
you know some people are having the
opposite more xenophobic response and
they're blaming the Chinese and things
like that and that's just wrong I mean
you know viruses and bacteria don't
discriminate they travel the world quite
freely and you know wherever they start
doesn't doesn't really matter as much as
exactly what you're saying that they
affect us all the same and and so yes I
I do think I mean it's going to be
really interesting to see you know we're
having this conversation somewhat at the
beginning of this being such a global
phenomenon I mean it's it's been in
China for a while it's really heating up
in the rest of the world and so I mean I
don't know about there in the UK here in
the u.s. every day some new restriction
is announced and I and it does feel now
like you can imagine what it before it
was sort of a novelty to watch the
people in China who were you know having
to stay home and were quarantined and
now we're all saying oh I guess we'd
better pay more attention to how they go
through that this is happening to me as
well and I you know and so yeah
it's it's these are challenging times
but it really is true that the that that
the so the way we're going to get
through it is connecting both with the
people that we already know and then
having empathy as you were just saying
for everybody else who's going through
the same thing I get it so you said that
about you the big differences between
having nan and one friend mm-hmm there
was a study that I heard cited a number
of times last year or the year before I
think where it said the most common
answer not the mean answer but the most
common answer to the question when asked
of Americans was how many friends do you
have that you could call on in a crisis
and the most common answer was zero is
that right did you look at this no
there's not right there was right there
was oh it's a little complicated let's
see there was a study a ways back that
that seemed to say that that there was a
tripling in the number of people who
said they didn't have any close people
they could rely on
but it was never everybody saying that
and and it turned out to be that there
was some there was some mix-up or some
methodological problems with the studies
so what what you're referring to is a
sort of long-running study in the US
where one of the questions they asked is
how many people have you discussed
important matters within the last six
months and if you say none zero then the
assumption was that you don't have any
close people to count on right but what
happened and it was only ever like so
usually the person number of people who
say that they have no one to count on or
to discuss important matters with and I
specify that because that is important
how they asked the question was in the
single percentages like 8 percent or 5
percent but in this one study it looked
like it jumped up to 24 percent but then
it turned out so that that's why you got
all of these headlines about a
loneliness epidemic and Americans are
you know have no friends and friendless
in America so the but the the truth is
that while it is true that loneliness
is a serious health problem and and on
some levels the numbers are growing
because the demographics are growing
it's also true that that jump didn't
really happen to that degree so it's
still more around under ten percent and
one of the reasons just is is that the
studies the way they asked the question
changed and the way also the way people
understood it changed so it turned out
that some people it wasn't they had no
one to discuss important matters with it
was that they had no important matters
to discuss in question the area of
causation rates so so anyway they're for
a bunch of reasons that that is not
quite right but you're not alone in sort
of grabbing hold of it and and thinking
that that is what's going on um but so
no Americans like everybody else have
you know an average of these smaller
circles of close friends and then larger
groups of people that they're close to
it you know to to lesser degrees moving
out in concentric circles okay so you
talked about brain size earlier on and
the reason for having bigger brains
potentially being that we have these
complex social structures we want to
understand how that's John John used to
go out with Joanne Joanne is the brother
the sister of this person blah blah um
is that where Dunbar's number comes from
did you look into Dunbar's number yes
so Dunbar's well Dunbar's number is 150
and he he is
he claims that that is the the number of
people that we can have meaningful
relationships with but not that that's
the number that we would consider close
friends because that's a much too big of
a number but that the number 150 shows
up in a lot of ways in society so
military units are often 150 people and
some kind of some societies set up sort
of their settlements at about a hundred
and fifty people and then they tend to
break off and make a new one there's a
lot of reasons to think that that is a
number that seems to make sense in in
for humans
but where that hundred-and-fifty
actually comes from too though is that
there's these series of concentric
circles in the way Robin Dunbar does his
his work as well and yes it's all based
on the social brain hypothesis which is
that idea that the complexity of our
social lives is dry has been driving the
size of our brains and and that we start
though with maybe five people in the
inner circle then it goes out in these
exponentially so 515 50 150 and actually
even further out from that I think he
says that fifteen hundred is about the
extent of names that we can actually
remember so you can have beautiful
relationships with a hundred and fifty
but you might know the names and faces
of fifteen hundred will recognize a
fifteen hundred yes right exactly so um
but but yes there's now since Robin
Dunbar made the social brain hypothesis
famous and there's been more sort of
conflict within the evolutionary biology
world and so it doesn't really we're
gonna let them fight it out in the
journals and let the scientists argue
amongst themselves that what they're
fighting about is whether it's the most
important reason for the size of human
brains but what's relevant for people
like you and me is that it doesn't have
to be the most important thing it can be
a major contributor right it's a big
part of why humans have the brains that
we have and it is definitely true that
our our societies are more complex than
anybody any other species and so it
makes sense that our brains had to
evolve to exactly as you said to keep
track of not just that I can't remember
we said Jo and Jo Ann and but then maybe
I shouldn't hit on so-and-so because I'm
prints it's not simply good enough to be
able to identify who they are it's to
understand their relative ranking
relationships between them and the
history and the way people interact and
the emotions and so we all have to have
you know we all have you were talking
about empathy earlier empathy is
complicated in your brain and so it
requires
all these circuits in your brain to
understand what somebody else is
thinking that they have a perspective
that might be different from yours and
that and that they believe things that
are different from what you believe and
that they don't see the world exactly
the way you see it and that is something
that that humans have sort of developed
to a fine art and it is fundamental to
our friendships and our ability to end
to socialize I get it so do all animals
make friends or during the course of
your research for the book did you find
is there like the the total introvert
animal out there there are some animals
who are more solitary for sure
like some of the big cats tend to
operate more on their own polar bears
male polar bears uh spend a lot of their
time on their own but a lot of animals
are very very social or they have they
have friendship or something like it
and in so in primatology where they
study monkeys and apes that's been
there's been really important work I
mean that's one of the things I focus on
in the book because that that work has
led to more of the breakthroughs in
understanding the evolutionary function
of friendship in humans and because
monkeys and apes have social behavior
that looks a lot like ours it's
obviously not exactly the same but
there's plenty there I mean I I spent
time watching monkeys in Puerto Rico and
baboons in Africa and I one of the
scientists I talked to said if you spend
a year watching the monkeys you'll never
look at humans the same way again I
think that's really true I mean you do
really see things about the way they
interact and they're also they have
different personalities just like we do
there's some that are kind of neurotic
and there's some that are bossy there's
some that are laid-back and some that
are charming and you know and and then
each of those is kind of a strategy for
how they interact with the other animals
in their in their troops the animals
that are the the species that are more
solitary a lot of them still do have
important bonds with each other though
so
it's interesting like even I don't know
there's there's different and I think a
lot of scientists are just beginning to
figure this stuff out or and starting to
study it in other species but even fish
have like social they have stuff going
on in their brains when they interact
socially that looks surprisingly like
what happens in human brains obviously
in a much simplified version but I mean
one of the things I cite in the book is
the story of zebrafish
who freeze when they come across a group
of unfamiliar fish and then they relax
when they can smell that they're with
familiar fish when they're the fish that
they normally hang out with and in their
brains neuroscientists believe it or not
could look inside the brain of a
zebrafish and they can see that there's
some socialize there's some activity in
the brain that looks a little bit like
what happens when you and I either are
hanging out with groups of people that
we're familiar with or when we come
across you know groups of strangers
that's pretty cool yes well I think yeah
ton men and women just to be friends yes
there is no biological reason why they
cannot just be friends I think that I
don't know this is just a speculation on
my part but I feel like culturally you
know we've set it up to make it feel
like that can't be true that men and
women can't be friends but but there are
lots of examples of men and women who
are friends and our only friends and and
of course if there's sexual attraction
that adds something different and it can
it can complicate things one of the
things that's interesting I mean you
asked me about what is friendship at the
beginning and what I didn't say and the
what we usually think of is that the
straightforward definition of friendship
is that it's someone with whom you do
not have sex and to whom you are not
related except except that you know we
have the phrase friends-with-benefits
right and we also often especially in
Western countries we like to imagine
that our romantic partners are our best
friends
often say that and it is interesting
because that is not universal there is a
study I cite in the book where they ask
people in Jacksonville Florida you know
do you think of your spouse as your best
friend and something like sixty percent
said yes and then they asked the same
question in Mexico City and almost no
one said yes exactly but I don't think
that has to do with the state of
marriage in Mexico as much as with the
habit of using the phrase the word
friend to describe your spouse they
think of them as two different things
right so when West when people who do
like to use the word friend are using it
to describe a spouse or a sibling or
somebody else like that that with whom
they have another kind of relationship
it's to add qualitatively to what you're
trying to say like if I tell you that my
husband is my best friend I say that
because I want you to understand
something about the strength of our
relationship right how positive it is
and it's so there's some ways in which
this science of friendship blurs the
lines so that sex and whether you're
related genetically matters less than
what does the relationship actually look
like I get the lines I want they are a
little word right and I think as well
there's because of the way that we adopt
societal norms and then make them our
own without realizing and then feed them
back out and think that there were our
own ideas you know this this romantic
version of your partner being your best
friend to someone from Mexico sounds
weird but to perhaps an English
literature student who's spent all of
their their time reading romance novels
and and you know Renaissance stuff at
Oxford University they have this
unbelievably different view of what both
romance and friendship are and also how
those those two can mingle as uh yeah I
like that um so I want to go on to the
the loneliness epidemic that we're
hearing about at the moment what what
did you look into regarding that
well here's the thing is that loneliness
is a public health problem it truly is
loneliness is bad for your health
just like friendship I mean it's two
sides of the same coin
so social connection and friendship is
really good for your health it's as
important for your health actually is
diet and exercise and loneliness is is
bad now one of the important points here
though is that when I say loneliness in
this context generally the definition
that the social psychologists are using
who we're doing this work is that
loneliness is the Mich mismatch between
the amount of social connection you want
and the amount you have right so if
you're completely satisfied to be home
watching Netflix all by yourself and you
know then you may be fine although a
caveat is that I find that there's
plenty of people who tell me how
introverted they are and how much they
don't want to socialize but I think
sometimes they're not being fully honest
with themselves or with me or whoever
about what they feel they're missing but
it's definitely true that there are some
people who are much more content to
spend more time alone than others and
there are people who are very lonely in
a crowd and so both things are true
right both things are possible so so
loneliness is about your perception of
how isolated you are or how connected or
disconnected you feel and if you the
problem with loneliness is that it
literally now we understand that it gets
inside your body in your biology and it
can make you sick and and so at first
everyone said well how is that possible
like a social relationship exists
outside your body right it's over here
it's like you know the food you eat you
can understand okay I'm eating this and
it's getting into you know so I can
understand why you know too much sugar
might be bad for me and vegetables are
good for my body and my health or when
you go for a run you're using your
muscles you're getting your heart rate
going so you can make the connection
much more easily to why it would have an
effect on your heart and your blood
pressure but it turns out that
loneliness on the one hand or social
connection on the other affect your
cardiovascular functioning so your heart
your blood pressure they've
your immune system and how resilient you
are to inflammation and viruses time
timely the fact that we're talking about
viruses today it affects your cognitive
health your mental health it affects
your stress responses and it even
affects the rate at which your cells age
so there's there's a little cap on your
cells called a telomere and it shortens
over time and it shortens faster in
people who are lonelier and that means
that they are biologically aging faster
it's like a little clock inside your
body
that's serious the implications are
really big how do I know if I'm lonely
then I can kid myself into believing
that I am or I'm not sometimes how can I
check if I'm lonely
well I mean I think you have to yeah
most people who are lonely do admit that
they're lonely so and it's I think that
loneliness and this is not just me
saying this I mean sorry some of the
researchers said this that loneliness is
your body's signal that you need to
connect just like thirst and hunger are
a signal that you need to eat or drink
and so if you're feeling it you should
take that as you should take that
seriously you should take that as a
warning of course the problem is that a
lot of lonely people say well but I'm
lonely but I can't you know what what am
I supposed to do about it because I have
no one to hang out with and and
unfortunately one of the things that
happens is that when we're lonely we
feel psychologically threatened it's a
little bit like being the animal on the
outside of the herd right and sometimes
the first thing to go are your social
skills actually so that is unfortunate
because it means that the people who
most need social connection are then
least able to achieve it it's a vicious
spiral right but what I hope is that
recognizing that and knowing that even
can can sort of help people be aware of
why they're behaving the way they're
behaving also to sort of say first of
all to say you need get out and connect
it possibly can and secondly have a look
at how you're behaving when you're doing
it and what kind of response you're
getting from people
and but you know I mean the ways to
connect are not are not it's not
complicated it's usually things like
shared interests so let's say people all
you know you live somewhere where
everybody likes to go hiking and you
love to go hiking there's probably a
club you can join right but or I was
just talking with people in Las Vegas
for a radio show and it turns out that
Las Vegas is famously unfriendly they
were having a you know it's a it's a
city where people there's very transient
a lot of people move in and then leave
and you know and so people some people
find it very hard to make friends but
they were telling me that there was a
whole group of people who were very
passionate about craft beers you know so
brewing bids no beers but did they all
like oh do they all have beards yes I
have no idea maybe they did maybe they
did but so they had this whole set of
social things that they set up around
craft beer and so the people who were
interested in that had these things they
could join in and go to these events all
about craft beers so I mean that that
example amused me but you know it can
apply all kinds of ways right and so I
do think one of the things that happens
is that when we're adults we often feel
like it's harder to make friends because
it is compared to when we were younger
and we were just sort of together with
people our same age all the time in this
easy way and you just had more
opportunity to build those relationships
so as an adult it's sort of you have to
go out and do it you have to be
motivated to do it you have to make
yourself vulnerable sometimes right you
have to put your like go to the event
full of people you don't know in hopes
of meeting someone you might like and be
friends with and nowadays apparently
there are apps to help people not to
date but to find friends like they're
specifically not meant for romance
they're meant for friendship and I think
that's really interesting it's a sign of
the times that that's you know that
that's where we're going but it also
tells you that this is something people
really want and need
and are looking for I think that's a
really really cool idea I remember
hearing about it a while ago I was
reading Marc Manson's models which is a
book about dating for men quite a while
ago and in that he talks about what is
the sort of woman that you want to date
what would be characteristics and you'd
say well that she has to go to the gym
and she really needs to be into reading
and I love a girl who does X Y and Zed
pick your characteristics and he's like
well that is where you go to find the
person you want to date do those things
you know yeah go to that you want a girl
that trains go at the gym you want to go
out in a reading go to a book club and I
think because of the way that the the
dating market is seen as something
that's a challenge to do I feel like
it's something where people go you know
finding finding the real the real guy or
the real girl it's actually actually
fairly challenging whereas you saying I
need to do the same thing I need to
optimize my strategy to get friends it
feels it feels like there's something
wrong even though there's nothing wrong
with that but it does there's something
about that sort of social leper what why
haven't you already got friends have you
not what's wrong with you what's the
reason for that you know right and this
is because we assume that it's easy and
we assume that it just comes naturally
and that and so I mean one of the other
things that I sometimes say is you know
it's clear from this research that
people need to prioritize their time
with friends and you know we spend a lot
of time booking in those hours we're
gonna be at the gym or whatever it is
but we don't do the same thing for our
friends they often fall to the bottom of
the list especially if we've just fallen
in love or dating somebody we tend to
ditch our friends right and it's not
that you shouldn't spend time doing
those other things but that time that
you were planning to go to dinner with
your friend and then keep canceling that
dinner is just as important for your
health as all these other things you're
doing and yet if I say to someone you
know you should schedule that and put it
in your calendar they're like oh that's
not that seems really you know corporate
or something yeah it seems forced except
point is find some way to make yourself
do it I don't really care how you do it
but I'm you know I do think that
actually if you can get your head around
thinking that it's important enough to
rape being scheduled or to be more
intentional about it like you're just
talking about with the dating then maybe
that won't feel so foreign to approach
it that way
we're so forced and you know because
that that's kind of the problem is that
we just haven't we haven't appreciated
enough how hard it is to do it well and
we haven't been explicit enough about
what's what it takes and and that
there's effort involved being in tension
with your friendships I really like I
think that's a good way to go about it
so how often do I need to see my friends
and how can I have better friendships
well how often you need to see your
friends is going to vary a bit according
you know we were talking earlier about
the introverts who like to spend time on
the couch and it's so it's not that
there's anyone it's not that there's any
sort of set amount of time what there is
is your own sense of your kind of
internal thermostat I guess we could say
you know I said earlier that loneliness
is the mismatch between the amount of
connection you have any amount that you
want and if you find yourself sitting at
home by yourself feeling lonely then
you've been you that should be a sign
that you're not getting enough time with
your friends and the but the way you go
about being a good friend is kind of an
echo of the definitions of friendship I
gave earlier so if being a good friend
if if a friendship is positive and
involves making each other feel good
then you should be working to make your
friends feel good you should be trying
to acknowledge every so often that you
care about them or what you know what if
they do something nice for you you
should be appreciative and the
reciprocal cooperative part it's really
really important not to just always be
on the taking side of that right and I
think sometimes we don't realize
not paying attention and I'm not trying
to say that it should be a very there's
not an accounting a tit-for-tat here
Yeah right it doesn't have to be like
that in the grand scheme of things it
should even out right so sometimes one
person needs more help than the other
and that's fine but what happens over
time is that if one person is always
kind of the needy one and does all the
talking never listens the other person
is going to find that draining in time
right so you really want to make sure
that that you are showing up for your
friends you're noticing what's going on
in their lives and you're responding and
you're commenting even if there's
nothing you can do about it just saying
wow that you know I realize this must be
hard or something like that means a lot
to people and people really just want
someone to listen and we're so often
we're busy waiting for our chance to
talk about ourselves right and not
really listening so and I really I said
it I said it in passing there but I just
think showing up in every sense of the
phrase is one of the most important
things you can do for your friend
whether it means showing up for like a
birthday party or the flipside like I
mean when my father died and I had
friends show up from all around the
world my friends not just his friends
but my friends that was so meaningful to
me right and or you show up right now
people are self isolating because of
coronavirus or you know you show up by
text or email or you call or you you
know and you set up ways to connect with
people and and some in this moment I
mean now there's level of disruption is
getting so severe that there's going to
be almost no one who's not badly
affected but some people are more
affected than others I mean I'm supposed
to be there in London right now you know
my books coming out I'm not I'm in
central New York and but like for
instance I have a son who just had the
rest of his senior year of college
cancelled which is harder than having
your sophomore year cancelled because
seniors are this was the end of their
time in college so the point is just
that you know some people are much more
effective than others and it's important
to at least notice and to acknowledge
that if you know somebody who's in an
hourly job that where they really
couldn't afford you know this I don't
know there's a lot a lot of people who
are really gonna suffer more than some
other people and so I my own sense of it
for it for me is you know like I'm aware
of my own disappointments and the
disruption that this is causing me but I
also recognize that it's so much worse
for so many other people right and so
you always have to have that perspective
I mean that's just kind of a an analogy
for how to be a good friend in general
is to notice what's going on with other
people and to keep your own life in
perspective yeah I've got a couple of a
couple of friendship hacks that I've
kind of come up with over lunch yeah
well that's your own so one of them is
actually a reflection upon doing the
podcast and I found having a deep
conversation with someone uninterrupted
focused on a topic where we both hold
ourselves hold each other to a high
level of I guess intellectual rigor or
at least precision with what we say now
he felt like that was a type of food
like a type of nutrition that I'd never
had I realized just how much I was
missing it when I started to do it and
then you know it's now two episodes a
week it was one Episode a week now it's
two episodes a week now the episodes are
a little bit longer blah blah blah and
honestly the I can't think of anyone for
whom they wouldn't enjoy it so I've said
one of the life hacks that we came up
with a couple of months ago was once a
week scheduled half an hour with someone
that you know to sit down and have a
conversation about something that you
care about you know just said no phones
left outside of the room focus on what
it is that you want to talk another one
of the ones that I came up with was
whenever you think about one of your
friends you I'm thinking about my buddy
from school or cricket or the gym or
whatever it is
text them takes them and tell them hey
man thinking of you hey dude the end of
you whatever it might be you know like
those little things and it made such a
difference with some of the the depth of
the friendships that I've got as well
and you it's what you said before it's
people being aware that you're there
people
seeing you feeling wanted feeling like
you're a part of something you know
between those two things telling people
when you miss them oh there's a third
one as well so it's called gasps your
friends up and it basically means we see
someone doing something good like you
you give them you kind of go a little
bit or all in on the compliments man
that's so beautiful that's that making
that's the positive part that's making
them feel appreciated I love it that's
great so there's there's three things
and you know maybe yes maybe someone
that's listening can apply that to their
life so I want you to finish up with
talking about digital friendships and
how they compare to real-life
friendships I think that's important you
know Cal Newport has this beautiful bit
in digital minimalism where he talks
about the difference between time on
your own and solitude because people in
solitude often will still have the input
of other minds and he defines solitude
pure solitude as time away from the
input of others which you means okay I
don't have your phone you don't have
your laptop you're not at the mercy of
email and what's up and mm-hmm Skype and
blah blah so how do digital friendships
map onto real friendships can I can I be
unlock down for the next four months
never see someone and just Skype
everyone and is that gonna make me feel
fine or well so these are unusual times
for this so my first answer is before
coronavirus is that on the one hand it
turns out that there's a raft of new
research showing that social media and
digital technology is not as harmful for
friendship and relationships as people
think it is it is true that having your
phone and up and in front in between you
and someone when you're together in real
life is terrible and we need to drop off
we need to put our phones down and we
need to focus on the people in front of
us but it's also true that if you use
social media as just one extra channel
with which to communicate with someone
that you see in other ways it
strengthens that bond that you have and
it's also true that people with bigger
online networks tend to have bigger
offline networks so there's this
mirroring of our online and
when lives that not everybody is always
acknowledging so most people who have
like you do thousands of Facebook
friends don't just have one friend that
they see in their private life offline
the the issue with social media
generally has been and it's looking more
and more like people for whom it
increases depression or anxiety and even
loneliness may already be suffering from
those things offline and so the question
of that that causation in which the way
the direction is going is a little bit
of a is up in the air now you know a lot
of people thought that social media was
the culprit but it now seems that for
the population at large that's not so
true what's happening is that the
science is getting better and sharper
and more rigorous but there are still a
lot of questions to be answered
all that said in this time of social
distancing and coronavirus we have to
embrace digital friendship because it's
what we've got you know it's it's the
the way that we can get through this and
and it is definitely true that while
it's different for you and me to be
talking this way on a screen instead of
in real life you know real life can't I
contact for instance it gets your social
brain going it triggers all the
communication parts in your brain in a
way that even a video chat like this
cannot do but but video chat is a whole
lot better than nothing
and it's really good to see people's
faces and not just to be texting them or
to you know so if if a video conference
through zoom with your friends is what
you can do while everybody's being
isolated for the next couple of months
then that's absolutely what you should
be do you should be doing and we're
really really fortunate that we have
this technology to help us get through
this time yeah it's the add-on it's the
dressing on the salad rather than the
salad itself so yeah no go ahead
I just hope when we reintegrate after
the coronavirus that it doesn't cause
people to to adopt this new world of
French
as how they're going to proceed moving
forward you know I mean yeah I hear you
I don't know I'm not afraid of that
because I really feel that into my
research it became so clear how much we
value and protect our close
relationships and that we we evolved
according to you know they are the
environment and our experience but we're
always working to protect those
relationships and there's a core of them
that always are going to involve in real
life activity face to face contact and
that hasn't changed that is still true
today even though we have these
different social lives on online we
still know who our good friends are we
still spend time with them offline and I
think we will return to each other
exuberantly hugging each other
high-fiving and having massive parties
to celebrate what am we can be together
in person okay thank you all right Lydia
thank you for today friendship your book
is out now right now it yes they can
order it it's out its out on the 19th of
March in the UK but you could pre-order
it right now I don't know when this is
going very well make it what's this 19th
so if it's not the link to promote it'll
be in the show notes below if it's out
the link that water will be in the show
notes below if people want to find you
online where should they go Lydia Lydia
dan worth com you can find everything
else is that's my website I'm on twitter
at Lydia den Worth I'm on Facebook at
science writer Lydia I'm I'm everywhere
but you can find all those things my
website leads to everything leads to my
books leads to my social media my
newsletter etc etc I love it hopefully
we've encouraged people to rekindle some
friendships and and also perhaps given
them some some ideas of how they can
continue to stay connected everything
gonna be distance I hope so and I hope
that this gives people permission to
think about friendship as a priority
instead of making it feel like something
you have to do I feel like it's
something you get to do right hey going
out with your friend is so important for
your health so go do it I love it Lydia
thank you so much
thank you Chris
[Music]
you